[Music]
hello welcome back to if you know you
know and today we're talking about the
corona virus and what's the current
situation with highly requested by the
wave by the citizens of Joe Mallya they
I asked them I was like hey we're gonna
be doing some CC you don't need to say
you know her on a corner and they were
like yeah just talk about this because
there's so much going on right now
there's a lot of different conspiracies
based off their just the corona virus
did you guys hear about that they
discover the corona virus they done
tests and it's the only way it's capable
of being made is if it's man-made that's
not what they said eat yeah and they
also said that the the receptor binds to
it's three times the amount in Asian
people than any other race so that's why
some people think it's just a weighted
like curb overpopulation that's another
one too so and that's part of what I was
talking about last week Bart where we
did a JK news about corner real quick
and I talked about how it's three times
more likely they'd be communicated
between people so you're saying it's
Asians Asians are the most susceptible
to it yes because whatever protein order
of receptor it binds to Asians have
three times amount than the other three
times versus the flu just to be clear
okay
and that's mighty too because my barber
like just if you caught it no no a few
days looks like you like don't worry
about it man I won't thank black people
I was like I found any cases of people
who have there is some African nations
that are just give it some time yeah I
know but I'm saying like but then that's
thing too so my girlfriend she works at
Costco and she says everybody's in there
like buy everything up right and then I
was like looking it up and I was just
like it doesn't seem like it's that big
of a thing at least in the states like
in terms of how many who it's affecting
and I also know one that's feel stupid
to be like oh I don't want to be like
don't worry about it guys it's just like
well six cases a lot of people who read
the news all day really do think that
we're all in LA like wearing masks and
being super [ __ ] right now they really
think right and it's not what that I was
just drove over today no one's over here
I was in the airport I just traveled I
went to playlist live in Orlando and
came back to LA and this happens like
every but seven years we have like this
like this newly up about we survived
SARS we survived bird flu swine swine
but more people have
Korona than those two diseases put
together so far so far but but as far as
the u.s. goes I mean I feel worse for
Iran for example or for obviously China
like we have had it so small compared to
those guys yeah and with our population
yeah it's really really good we're
taking a pretty active kind of like like
measures against trying to like make
sure that it doesn't hit us as hard as
Italy got cases right now yeah my friend
actually you got flung out beat a lot of
our airlines are also just stopping
travel to the destination there's a did
a month ago there's a big outdoor show
in um in Germany that they they had so
many people like there's a lot of Asian
vendors going to that too but those
Asian vendors pulled out and they're
just like yeah we're just gonna move the
whole thing to like September like you
look it up right now you wait for it all
blow yeah and then those concerts and
stuff like I think that it's cool that
people are kind of postponing a lot of
these big public gatherings cuz you know
especially Japan's not there like the
Olympics is going I heard Rome I heard
rumbles about like oh should we you know
potentially a post I just read article
this morning that it said that they were
like no we're new any but aren't they
the fifth country or they're pretty high
up there we know they are [ __ ] up with
the cruise ship though huh apparently
they [ __ ] up with a cruise ship though
cuz they wouldn't let the cruise ship
dock and neither did everyone on the
cruise ships Japanese got ranking it you
know because it was a Princess cruise
ship right it was turned away
yeah it's turned away or whatnot and
then way from where to where like from
where to where
who's Japan they turned away Wow but so
the whole ship got sick it was like 700
people or something cuz they just cut
them in there and then Cap'n because
they're trying to quarantine them like
you don't want to let anybody off yeah
cuz it takes a lot for the symptoms to
present so you could have somebody
that's in fact you don't it'll take like
like few days at the quickest before you
see it
I don't like takes latency an incubation
period of like seven days yeah well the
incubation can be longer but the
symptoms of wanting to be transmitting
it as you're you know incubate didn't
Greece also shut the border down
I don't know about Greece I don't know
but north of Italy so Austria's not
taking in any more trains from Italy
Michael actually the other day are
Michael his family member he was telling
you about that yes
suck on that cruise ship cruise two of
them have Corona but they don't have
crazy symptoms like it's just a little
bit of sickness yes we're talking about
that that one none of that is chronic
say oh yeah multiple ones right yeah
yeah this high possibility but still
like as far as compared to the whole
Cruise Line out there like I'm talking
about those are the ones that have grown
on but the scary thing about Corona
though is the there's people that are
having relapse recover they'll go out
and then they'll get they'll get it
again and they're saying that by the
third time it's death and that's the
scary thing because now there hasn't
been enough stages yet where people are
getting it two times three times and
then they're saying that the third time
you get it you did that's the crazy part
cuz uh viral infections you're not
supposed to get twice even to the point
where you know when you get the flu
vaccination what they're giving you is a
mild form of it right so the minute your
body develops antibodies to that flu the
second time it comes around your body is
already immune to it because already has
it antibodies so it's crazy that for
someone to get the corona virus they
beat it which means they have developed
new antibodies for and now another verb
it comes or no actual cures to viral
infections also right like like so it's
mutating flu we get a different flu shot
every year there's so many strains and
stuff so I mean like why is it seasonal
you know that's the weird thing right
because flu season yeah like the eyes
wouldn't really flu every year like
where is it incubating during the summer
I'm like no one's getting I think it has
to do a cold weather though something
about cold weather that allows people
that well the virus is always around
it's just when it's cold your immune
system is on getting hyper it's like on
hyperdrive so it's easier for you to get
cold I'm gonna to catch a flu
oh so it's that more people have weaker
immune systems during the winter right
so then they're susceptible to viruses
and so the viruses are around all the
time
it's just like it's just like if you
have what is it it's HIV or AIDS which
ones the one one that that comes first
is HIV AIDS my your Debby you're
susceptible to all the things that
you're normally not susceptible to that
are still around but because we have
normal immune systems we find it off but
because your immune system is so
compromised
point that's why you get all these yes
bring that up man thanks a lot oh yeah
oh yeah so going back to the
conspiracies that surround it okay one
of them is it's either China that
manufactured it and they're gonna use it
as a biological warfare or whatever but
then it leaked out it went offline yeah
another one is it's America it's an
antithesis to what you said if trying to
developed it in it's only targeting
agents that's the one that doesn't make
sense to me cuz I don't I can't really
find the motor and that the one where
it's like why it's targeting gage why
China would make it for their own people
so the idea is that it was to attack
Hong Kong or do least have you noticed
the protests dispersed since then that's
one of the conspiracies behind that
because I'm not really remember with
Tiananmen Square they're saying that if
everyone got sick at Tiananmen Square
then they would have just went home so
they're saying or if they were afraid of
getting seconds of what I heard from
Hong Kong locals is that the situation
in China was getting worse
so that there were protests happening in
Hong Kong but what was happening
internally in China there was more [ __ ]
that was going down that the Western
media wasn't cuffed it was affecting
China like actually the Hong Kong
protests were affecting Chinese minds
and making them more sympathetic exactly
so the best thing to do is just knock
out all those protests that's part of
the conspiracy right is so if people
gather in groups are more likely to get
sick and maybe die yeah so that's you
know that's what that theory is I have
my own hypothesis as to what's going on
so like I'm thinking this if America did
send in this it's because we're in a
trade war currently and China yeah I
don't think America sent two thoughts I
think if they did though I can see why I
can see why motive wise because almost
overnight China created a network of
highways in the way that we choked
people other nations basically is we
[ __ ] up their trade routes and we
control them that way so we own the Seas
from Southeast Asia all the way out
right they don't really have a way to
trade with the rest of us in the other
other other world if we control that
space and then if we choke them out with
trade then we can hurt their economy but
if they they basically created the new
South silk
behind her backs really [ __ ] self
courtesy yes well it goes to it's like a
network that goes into Europe and
everything and land where is it it's
over land so Bo they they technically
can't do the sea route because of us
well no they they've been doing it
though South China Sea China has been
making oh you're talking about the new
islands that they're creating okay
that's another thing right yeah pushover
they even make it major major moves that
we're pissed about when I saw that I go
okay so this is our response to to
hurting them in another way so that's
very plausible I just don't think that
we did it because I think that I think
that we economically benefit from China
yeah it would be bad for business if we
did that's all that's all I'm cynical
suppose like you I don't think that we
care about human lives or whatever the
[ __ ] I think it's about the money
because at the end of the day look at
what it's doing to our stocks it crushed
them and then we just had a huge day
yesterday but then who the [ __ ] knows
there's so much uncertainty right but
it's like why would we want to do that
because it's gonna hurt the factories
all of my friends that are doing
business with China they're pissed
because they're like oh my watches won't
come in my orders won't come in because
the factories are closed down and now
it's affecting the money so why record
on economy so that that's part of it and
then also I think that there's something
to be said about what China's interests
are why would China do that to Hong Kong
knowing that it could get out spread
into their own population I think it's I
think it's plausible that they might be
developing bioweapons though I think
it's totally plausible that they would
be doing that because it feels like I
don't know about you guys but it feels
like Khan we're in this like weird stale
milk cold war like proxy what kind of
things I think that you know just like
in the Cold War were experimenting
experimenting and testing out all these
weird new weapons and stuff like I can
see them making it just being like oh
like we don't want to use it yet but
like we know why not have it we're
definitely developing bio weapons all
countries are LeGrande yeah so you think
it's good to be a leak it could make big
it's a leak I just think that it's just
one of those things that's like I mean
like just look at nuclear power and
stuff like that like people [ __ ] up cuz
human error and then you have like big
you know massive like you know
catastrophes and this could just be one
of those like whoops oh man that's like
the plot for every like the zombie
apocalypse is that is a [ __ ] yeah it's
human error which is totally plausible
for me and it's totally plausible that
like China was developing this and
they're just like no just
doing that at all that would explain why
they silenced it for their gonna silence
it either way because it looks bad that
everyone's getting sick in their country
it could have just just mutated to to
fit Asian genes like it might have not
been intended I could have been yeah
unintentional it also you know I think
that there's something to be said about
so there was a professor who was
arrested in who's a Harvard professor
and he was arrested for working with
China and one of the other spy yes and
one of the things that he does it has to
do with by owed by owed warfare whoa
yeah there's a lot to be said about
what's going on right now and what we
have informational II compared to what
the probably real story is I think we're
only just getting to know it there's a
lot though and then there's um recently
there was like a like a politician that
was tweeting out like conspiracies based
on the corona virus and just there's
just so much [ __ ] that's surrounding
this that I feel like no one would
really know until years later
exactly so we're just getting a [ __ ]
tip of the iceberg here just like when
the recession went down no one really
knew what happened until later there you
go oh yeah the mortgages
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]